bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors comment on explique
cette nouvelle nuit de violence et
comment
qu'est-ce qu'il a déclenchée oui bonjour
écouter offert très simple en fait on
s'aperçoit au jour d'aujourd'hui que
parmi les dix ici une banlieue s'embrase
un peu pour que les autres suivent donc
pour rappel il ya quatre jours basse
effectivement que vous l'avez dit sur la
commune de la duchère dans médias le
brunissement avant dire c'était sur ie
il ya ça c'était sûr gros voilà
effectivement ce ne sont pas des faits
nouveaux
pas du tout les violences urbaines
existe depuis des années un nos
collègues fort nationalisme
ça va les gérer on a effectivement hier
à déplorer il va sont importantes ce
sont des bus mais également sur un
véhicule de police
heureusement les grecs n'étaient pas à
l'intérieur alors on vous le dit on ce
n'est pas en fait nouveau le meur de
bron d'ailleurs réagi et il a dit je
cite le temps du laxisme est terminée
qui a fait preuve de laxisme coûté en
tout cas on compare que ce soit sous la
banlieue lyonnaise est en général il n'y
a pas de zone de non droit nos collègues
banques partout dans tous les secteurs
dans tous les quartiers
la police n'a jamais lâché le terrain et
ne lâchera pas le terrain bien au
contraire
ce genre de violences urbaines de faux
semblants renforcer sur place et donc
façon il y aura davantage de policiers
sur place et nous continuerons pour
qu'il en soit le délégué explique andy
on ne lâchera rien et mes collègues ce
soit voilà s'il faut continuer on
continuera en sera là sera présent alors
me disiez en effectif de polisseur
renforcer gérald darmanin annoncé
l'envoi d'une nouvelle unité des forces
mobiles 200 policiers et gendarmes
est-ce que selon vous c'est suffisant
l'unsa-police depuis dix années elle
demande notamment sur sur lyon et son
agglomération des renforts de police pas
des renforts ponctuels comme si le cas
ce week end à son collègue de bonnes
choses
par milliers les crs et des gendarmes
mobiles et leurs fonctionnaires donc
trois quatre jours ils sont plus là
et donc on va en revenir au même niveau
qu'à l'habitude c'est à dire guillaume
moins de 300 policiers
donc monsieur norman a effectivement le
27 juin de cette charge janvier par bon
lorsqu'il est venu sur les ondes a
annoncé des renforts d'effectifs pour
l'année en cours donc à savoir qu'en
2008 l'un de ces noms ne peut avoir deux
cents fonctionnaires qui arrive sur lyon
bien coûter en a pris hâte au jour
d'aujourd'hui on ne l'a pas encore vu la
couleur mais on espère ça va arriver et
il ya eu également des effets d'annoncés
notamment sur les lieux et sur vaulx en
velin qui pourrait être donc au quartier
de conduite peu de répit aux parents est
effectivement 10 betty de plus ce rieux
25,2 en place une bonne chose mais au
jour d'aujourd'hui nous sommes en mars
et toujours rien n'est mis en place
voilà donc on attend vraiment c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui mis dans la
précipitation sur deux ou trois jours il
faut sauver rampeau appétit scoop mais
est-ce que vous avez des retours sur le
terrain est ce que les forces de l'ordre
font enquête pour les jours à venir
non on ne peut plus inquiet que ça une
eau non connexion là je vous le dis on
l'habitude de ces violences urbaines 1
c'est vraiment pas nouveau
donc voilà donc on gère effectivement le
poème d'effectifs pourrait plan on a des
compagnies départementales
d'intervention qui sont censés
normalement intervenir dans ces
violences urbaines au jour d'aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que le seul avenir i spy
au long cours des packs parfois des
groupes de soutien public et parfois
même des équipes du matin et ça c'est un
problème
christophe pradier merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france je
rappelle que vous êtes délégué
départemental adjoint du rhône unsa
police merci à vous